or now by our next guest Labor's shadow
Housing Minister Sarah Jones thank you
very much for being with us and now I'm
keen to talk about housing big issue for
many people but I just want to start
with a story that we've really been
focusing on on Sky News over the coming
days and it's about a 19 year old
harridan
killed in a road traffic accident and
the suspect is somebody who is the wife
of a diplomat she's returned to the u.s.
claiming diplomatic immunity what do you
think the government needs to do now
well I've heard the interview with
Harris family and it's absolutely
heartbreaking and you know of course we
want the Foreign Secretary to be having
the conversations to try and and get
some justice into this it's hard enough
that you lose a loved one so young but
you you have to you have to know that
there's going to be some kind of justice
done in terms of what happened and and
and holding those people to account so I
think it's it's right that the foreign
secretary should have those
conversations with the Americans to try
and see if we can resolve the situation
and well done tit - you for raising it
because it's really important do you is
it something that you quite like to see
labor pick up and put some pressure on
with as well I think I think everybody
will look at the family and go goodness
this is this is unfair and we need to
see some conversations take place and
some pressure put on to try and get
justice done okay
thank you and now let's talk about
housing shall we because there was some
quite radical policies that were
discussed in relation to housing at
Labour's conference I'm keen to get your
view on to try and work out what the
next steps are when it comes to what
labor is trying to achieve so one of
them was to requisition by compulsory
purchase order empty private homes I
mean is that effective of the state
ceasing private property what is that so
we've got a whole package of proposals
that the Labour Party have put forward
and a conference our conference members
kind of pushed us to go further on on a
whole range of issues and that the
underlying problem we have here is the
housing crisis of quite huge proportions
which is kind of in many different
layers you have the problem with with
homelessness we've had 700 deaths in
of people on our streets dying because
they don't have a home and all those
families in bed and breakfast but we
also have you know a conservative party
where homeownership has gone down where
you have a nearly a million under
forty-fives who are unable now to buy
their home who would have been you have
really unfit private rented
accommodation you have all the impact of
the out of Grenville and what's what's
happened since in terms of an
understanding now that our building
controls are so weak that we have
thousands of people living in unfit
homes and we have climate change so all
of those things of what our members
looked at and one of those points was
what do we do about about homes that are
empty which is a completely reasonable
question because we've all seen those
blocks
you know perhaps ones where people buy
flats too as an investment and nobody's
actually living them and we want to make
sure we look at that compulsory purchase
power and I think the Conservatives I've
you know spoken too many back benches in
the Conservative Party as well who want
to look at these powers so you are we do
you are comfortable then with the idea
of going into a property that has been
empty and effectively the state taking
it well what we've said so far in our in
our policies that we've announced is
that we'd put an increase in council tax
on those homes that are empty so that if
you're but we'll talk about compulsory
purchase yeah and that's and that was
what was in the conference motion and
that's the kinds of issues that we're
looking at like a walking later in your
considering we're looking at whole range
of issues around what do we do with
empty homes there are hundreds of
thousands of empty homes but the bigger
problem the bigger problem is that this
government is building fewer social
homes than ever since the war we need to
be building council homes we need to be
helping people who want to own their own
home get into homeownership we've seen
very peculiar announcements from the
Secretary of State in terms of right to
buy a share ownership of housing
associations which the housing sector
have said is a completely bum deal and
won't work and we've seen nothing on the
the the scale that will actually
begin to address the housing problem
that we face in this can all agree on
some of the issues but its solutions
that have the difficult bit right and
and we're talking about right to buy I
mean John McDonnell gave an interview
recently the Shadow Chancellor talking
about giving tenants the right to buy
their rented homes at a knockdown price
is that something that Labor's
considering so he's looking at this he's
been interested in it for a while again
there are there were that conservative
think tanks that have been putting out
reports on on how that might work for a
long time we want more people who want
to buy to be able to we have a product
that we've already and now it's called
first buy which would give you a
discount on your home so that can get
more people into homeownership that the
discount stays with the property not
with the person so it's fairer than
other systems we've said we want to
suspend right to buy in in council homes
because what's happened is home but what
about giving tenants the right to buy
their house at a knockdown price so
that's something that they that we
haven't announced as policy it's
something that our the Jama Donald's
looking at that John Healey shadow
sector estate for housing is looking at
it's something that's being debated
across the political divide is there
some kind of first dibs if the house is
for sale but that could go to the tenant
is there some kind of tax break that
would incentivize the that the landlord
or the tenant to be able to to buy that
guess my question is who decides what is
a knockdown price because I'd be some
people who you know have a house that
they want to let out for whatever reason
it is maybe they need to move away for
work and they're going to be worried
that somebody else as in the state will
decide how much they need to sell their
house for and effectively I don't think
we're talking about anything like that I
think what we're looking at in private
renting at the moment is you've now got
one in four families living in private
rented accommodation the biggest problem
for them is the lack of security because
we have this clause where you can be
evicted for any reason the second
problem is that is the huge costs of of
housing which are pushing many people
into poverty in this country you know
hundreds of thousands of of children
living in private rented accommodation
that because of the cost of it
that family those children are in
poverty and you've got really poor
standards in the private renter sector
with no control
what happened so there's a whole array
of things we need to be doing now and
I've got them King to us proper exit and
horse it feels like we can't get away
with it I'm not asking in any of our
interviews and I just wanna have a quick
look at something that you said on
question time this week you said on a
brexit Labour's position is not a
soundbite it's not easy to explain it
has its difficulties the point is it's
honest is that the agreed party line
that your break set policy isn't easy to
explain and that it has its difficulties
what I was saying is the get brexit done
conservative let's break the law if we
have to you know extraordinary purse
also they are so that they will obey the
laws let's be fair how do you do that
and also not ask for an extension the
law of the land is that if he doesn't
get a deal the Prime Minister has to ask
for an extension how can he not do that
so Labor's position breaking the law so
that is the most extraordinary thing
that here we are talking about what do
we do if a man who were sacked twice for
lying whose own sister thinks he's in
bed with hedge funds whose only friend
in the cabinet amber rod had to resign
because she didn't believe he was
actually serious so Labor's position why
delayed Association the course that we
have the conservative view which is out
we go whatever happens we have the Lib
Dem view which is less than it has it
ever happened you know we never had this
referendum where the people actually
made a decision so let's forget it all
Labour's position is really clear we
have to put it back to the people what I
was saying is but it's honest and it's
it's the only compromise position
between these two extremes where
everybody's getting very angry and
fighting each other over these two
extreme views on it clear but also not
easy to explain because it's not get
breakfast done it's not a kind of
soundbite that's being thrown us every
second of every day but it's the right
position we want to say look the people
voted to leave in 2016 they didn't say
how we leave and there are a million
different ways to do that the Prime
Minister's deal will jeopardize the Good
Friday Agreement one of the most
important things that we have that holds
our nation together and the Prime
Minister's deal will get rid of all our
standard so we can have the chlorinated
chicken of
erricka that we're soaking to avoid our
view is we need to put it back to the
people to say here are two positions
that are reasonable one is a deal that
actually keeps us closer we don't
threaten jobs and one is that we remain
and that is the right honest view that I
think actually at the end of the day
will be what we do going forward